former top official at the Federal
Emergency Management Agency faces
accusations of sexual harassment and
even hiring women as possible partners
for male workers his story is almost too
hard to believe
FEMA's administrator said some of the
activities could rise to the level of
criminal activity
Jephthah gazes in Washington with these
allegations Jeff good morning good
morning Cory Coleman has been the
subject of an internal investigation for
seven months and in June resigned before
a scheduled interview with investigators
but what they know so far is leading to
a review of sexual harassment policies
within that agency hello my name is
Corey Coleman the allegations against
Coleman are outlined in a preliminary
report investigators say he harassed
women and even hired some women as
potential sexual partners for male
employees and I'm famous deputy chief
component human capital officer Coleman
who began working at FEMA in 2011 also
allegedly hired dozens of men who were
friends and college fraternity brothers
in his capacity as FEMA's chief
component human capital officer he is
suspected of transferring some of the
women he hired in and out of departments
so his friends could try to have sexual
relationships with them Coleman is also
accused of having sexual encounters with
two subordinates the ongoing
investigation has rattled the agency
whose 20,000 employees are tasked with
responding to disasters like the
hurricanes in Puerto Rico Texas and
Florida
FEMA's administrator Brock long called
the allegations deeply disturbing and
requested further investigation by the
DHS office of the inspector general
Gouri Coleman is not responded to the
allegations leaders in the House of
Representatives issued a rare bipartisan
statement saying that they were outraged
by the revelations a FEMA hearing has
been delayed until after the
investigation is completed
Anthony Jeff the gays thank you Jeff